you know that I've been talking about
the disgusting and immoral alliance
between the United States and Saudi
Arabia for years
it is a hypocritical and horrible
alliance it exists in part because of
the shared goal of stability in the
Middle East that both the US and Saudi
Arabia have but ideologically there is
little difference between the Wahhabist
extremism of Saudi Arabia and the other
radical Islamic sects in the Middle East
that the u.s. is actively fighting
against and the news about this alliance
is getting even worse unless you felt
that the Middle East needed even more
weapons the US State Department has
approved the potential sale of more than
a hundred and thirty battle tanks twenty
armored armoured recovery vehicles and a
whole bunch of other equipment worth
about 1.15 billion dollars to Saudi
Arabia now this could potentially still
be vetoed by lawmakers rarely happens
basically does not happen General
Dynamics will be the principal
contractor for the sale this is just
good old-fashioned military-industrial
complex Lewis with the caveat and a few
people emailed me suggesting this
recently you know how we've talked about
how the Pentagon has actually said
recently we don't need as many tanks as
we've sort of committed to buying what
let's spend less money you're giving us
more equipment than we even need sort of
fits in neatly to that messaging that
now all of a sudden Saudi Arabia might
be buying tanks from the United States
although that is just merely speculation
are we confident Louis that these tanks
these hundred and thirty tanks that will
be sent to Saudi Arabia will be used to
defend democracy it won't really be
defending democracy it'll be defending
Saudi Arabia and and the oil fields
which we rely on it's a the idea and
from the statement released was that
this is all about stability Saudi Arabia
is an ally they might continue to be an
ally this is this to help maintain
stability it's a good good faith all
that and I don't see this country
falling apart in the foreseeable future
but but it may and it
some other points it may and then there
will be this plethora of tanks and
weapons that we sold being used against
us potentially and it's the same story
over and over again when you sit down
and think about this situation for what
it is it's sort of will cause
indigestion we know that Saudi Arabia
was actually tied to the 9/11 attacks we
invaded Iraq after those attacks but
continued to sell Saudi Arabia weapons
interesting now that this happens both
in terms of the timing regarding the
tanks but also in the midst of huge
human rights abuses in Saudi Arabia that
we've talked about time and again things
are probably going to get way crazier in
the Middle East soon as well over water
and you and I Lewis have been talking
about this for a while we've spoken to
economists about it the entire Middle
East basically with the exception of
Israel that has now actually started a
desalinating water they've just made a
huge advance in terms of distilling
water drinkable water from seawater
which was previously completely
economically untenable the entire Middle
East other than Israel is going to be in
really rough shape as far as water
availability starting very soon and I
can only imagine that the natural
resource Wars could be pretty well
served by having an extra 130 tanks no
doubt yeah Saudi Arabia is I mean the
more the more capital you have the the
better off you'll be when when the water
shortages happen another interesting
thing about this sale is that it does
this mean anything about the looming
threat of Isis does this have anything
to do with Isis is are they more of a
threat to Saudi Arabia than we thought
right or is this just business as usual
yeah even though Saudi Arabia and Isis
actually share some social beliefs they
don't like each other and have declared
war Isis has declared war on Saudi
Arabia or vice versa or maybe both now I
don't remember but but be that be that
as it may they don't like each other
that we know